we have seen more than 10 problems based
on permutations and combinations and we
have used logic to solve all of those
once we understand the logic there is no
harm in using the formulae which we will
see in this session we know that
permutation is about arranging things
and combination is about selecting
things but we need to get a deeper
understanding of this is it extremely
easy to figure out the difference
between arrangement and selection before
we get to a few examples let's
understand the notation if we have to
arrange our things out of n it's written
as NPR arranging our things out of n we
use P as its permutations and for
selecting our things out of n we write
it as NCR C for combinations let's zoom
out and discuss each of these in detail
permutations is about arrangement but
what does this arrangement tell us what
is it that explains this word it tells
us that the order matters the ordered
which the things are placed matters ABC
and ACB will be different one two three
will be different from two three one and
so on
and what about combination combination
is selection selection is simply picking
a few things here the order does not
matter say from the digits 1 2 3 4 5 we
picked up 1 3 & 4 picking up 1 3 4 is
the same as picking up 4 1 3 they are
not two different cases let me give you
a permutation example assume we have to
pick a team of three people out of the
available ten one of them will be chosen
as a vice president another as a manager
and another as a product developer this
is the classic case of permutation the
order matters if we select a B and C
then it can be a case of VP manager
product developer or maybe a is chosen
as a product developer B
as vice president and see as a manager
each case is different on the other hand
if we are asked to select a leadership
team of three out of ten and told
nothing else about it then it is a case
of combination the order does not matter
selecting a B and C is the same as
selecting B C and a or C a and B take
another example say 2 out of 5 people
get ice cream one gets vanilla and the
other gets chocolate this is the case of
permutation as each of the two people
selected may get either vanilla or
chocolate flavored ice cream and if
we're just told that 2 out of 5 get ice
cream it will be a case of combination
we aren't told anything else just that 2
out of 5 get ice cream so the order
clearly does not matter now that we have
understood what permutations and
combinations are we can move on to the
formulae first we look at NPR arranging
our things out of n distinct objects and
repetition is not allowed for example
let's assume we have digits 1 2 3 & 4
and we have been asked the number of
ways in which we can form three-digit
numbers using these four digits for this
formula we cannot consider cases such as
111 or 232 or 441 the digits are
repeated in each case so the objects
have to be distinct and there can be no
repetition so this equals n factorial
divided by n minus R factorial yes
that's the formula if we have to arrange
three people out of ten it will equal 10
factorial divided by 10 minus 3
factorial don't worry we will look at
numerical examples later for now let's
just look at the formulae we move on to
combinations now NCR it's selecting
three things from ten distinct things
this will equal n factorial divided by
factorial times n minus R factorial yes
that's the formula for combinations if
we have to select two out of five the
number of ways in which it can be done
is five factorial divided by 2 factorial
times 5 minus 2 factorial at first these
formulae look scary but as you start
practicing you will see that using these
formulae gets us the answer really quick